OF WHAT'S YOURS.
>> Tucker: THE WHITE HOUSE
PROPOSED IMMIGRATION DEAL GIVES
A MAJOR CONCESSION TO DEMOCRATS
FOR DACA MEMBERS AND A MILLION
OTHER PEOPLE.
DEMOCRATS ARE REJECTING IT.
THEY CLAIM THE DEAL DEMANDS
INCREASED BORDER SECURITY TO
HOLD DREAMERS HOSTAGE AND A FORM
OF WHITE  SUPREMACY.
NANCY PELOSI CALLED THIS RACHEL.
IS IT?
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
IMMIGRATION A LOT WITH.
THE YEAR I WAS BORN 1969, THE
UNITED STATES HAD 20022 MILLION
PEOPLE.
IT'S NOW MORE THAN 60% INCREASE.
THREES LATER EVEN HIRE. MILLION
PEOPLE.
IT'S NOW MORE THAN 60% INCREASE.
THREES LATER EVEN HIRE.
ALL OF THAT IS DUE TO
IMMIGRATION.
MY QUESTION TO YOU IS:
WHAT IS THE RIGHT NUMBER?
IMMIGRATION SHAPES THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE HERE.
IT DRIVES IT.
HOW MANY PEOPLE SHOULD LIVE IN
THIS COUNTRY?
>> THAT'S AN INTERESTING
QUESTION.
I HAVE NOT THOUGHT THROUGH THAT.
I FEEL LIKE IT'S ONE WORTH
DISCUSSING AND TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT OUR POLICY SHOULD BE
WITH REGARD TO GROWTH.
>> Tucker: ISN'T THAT THE
A COUNTRY.
THE COST OF INFRASTRUCTURE AND
SCHOOLS AND HEALTH CARE IS
CONNECTED TO POPULATION.
IT CHANGES THE COUNTRY.
WHY HAVE YOU NOT THOUGHT ABOUT
THAT?
>> WELL, I GUESS, WHAT I AM
INTERESTED IN RIGHT NOW IS A
MUCH SMALLER GROUP OF PEOPLE.
A NARROW ISSUE WHICH IS THE
DREAMERS.
AND MAKING SURE THAT THEY HAVE A
PATHWAY TO CITIZENSHIP HERE IN
THE U.S.
YOU THINK IN BIG WAYS AND I TRY
TO BE NARROWER.
>> Tucker: BECAUSE IT CHANGED
THE COUNTRY I GREW UP IN SOME
WAYS FOR BETTER AND SOME WAYS
FOR WORSE.
CROWDING IS BAD.
BEIJING IS A DISASTER.
IF YOU ARE FOR THE DREAMERS,
THEN YOU MUST BE HAPPY WITH THIS
PROPOSAL FROM THE WHITE HOUSE
THAT GIVES THEM AMNESTY?
WE BELIEVED ALL THE LEFT WANTED
WAS AMNESTY.
HERE TOO AND GET PUBLIC
SERVICES.
HOW DOES THAT WORK?
>> I DON'T THINK ANYBODY IS
ARGUING FOR ALL THEIR RELATIVES
FOR PUBLIC SERVICES.
THERE IS AN INTERESTING BILL OUT
THERE.
VERY BIPARTISAN FROM CONGRESSMAN
HERD, A REPUBLICAN AND FROM A
CONGRESSMAN A DEMOCRAT.
52 CO-SPONSORS.
DOES WHAT WE NEED TO DO WHICH IS
FOCUS ON THE DREAMERS TO HAVE A
PATHWAY TO CITIZENSHIP AND
WHAT THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS
TRYING TO DO IS REALLY DRIVEN BY
THE KITCHEN SINK.
[OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> Tucker: HOLD ON.
WAIT, WAIT.
QUESTION.
I HEAR FROM PEOPLE INCLUDING YOU
IT'S IN AMERICA'S ECONOMIC
INTEREST TO LET THESE PEOPLE IN.
THE MAJORITY ARE FROM MEXICO.
IF THAT'S TRUE, IF A LOT OF
LOW-WAGE LABOR MAKES A COUNTRY
RICH, WHY ISN'T MEXICO RICH?
>> ARE WE TALKING ABOUT THE
PEOPLE WE ADMIT EVERY YEAR FOR
WHY AREN'T THE COUNTRIES FROM
WHICH THEY ARE COMING RICH IF
LOW WAGE LABOR IS THE KEY TO
PROSPERITY?
>> I DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOUR
FAMILY.
LET'S LOOK AT MOST AMERICAN
FAMILIES AND HOW THEY GOT HERE
THROUGH IMMIGRATION.
WHICH IS THAT PEOPLE COME TO THE
UNITED STATES BECAUSE OF WHAT IT
THEY ARE COMING FOR ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES.
THIS IS HOW THE IRISH,IITALIANS
AND CHINESE CAME.
>> Tucker: I AM JUST ASKING A
SIMPLE QUESTION.
HOW WILL WE BENEFIT ECONOMICALLY
FROM CONTINUED LOW-WAGE
IMMIGRATION?
I AM NOT ASKING IF IT'S MORALLY
GRATE.
-- GREAT.
I NEVER GET AN ANSWER.
>> IMMIGRATION SIGNIFICANTLY
BENEFITS THE U.S. ECONOMY.
>> Tucker: THAT'S A LIE.
YOU SHOULD NOT HAVE SAY THAT IF
>> Tucker: WE ARE ALMOST OUT OF
RELIES ON IMMIGRANTS TO
SUBSIDIZE THE PEOPLE WHO ARE